you said you're an
army brat and um so you've got a lot of
love for the military because i always
hear about
how you travel all over to do these uh
is it um
uso yeah uso appearances yeah how many
how many times have you flown like uh
overseas to do uso stuff i i
can't even count anymore like i know
it's been over
10 or 15. we've done it for we did it
for seven years straight
and then i've always always for free
yeah yeah and then i've gone uh
around the world clockwise on two
different trips
in one week in eight days we'd start in
la flight in new york
new york till then like italy italy then
to like germany
germany to like afghanistan then like
and we would go clockwise in eight days
and just
visit different troops out in different
areas are you flying like a military
plane
yeah we actually we've flown a couple of
times
on uh air force two the vice president's
plane
so we've flown on that twice and then
we'll fly on
yeah then we've flown on c17s the big
ones that carry tanks and stuff
and all kinds of different aircraft
what's the vice president's plane like
oh that thing is
tits just think of a private jet but
747 size yeah
i mean if it's if it's air force two you
would imagine it's probably the same
[ __ ] thing as air force one right
yeah
yeah exactly yep so how many of these uh
how many of these uso trips did you go
into just full-on war zones
uh i've been in uh three i believe
i went i went to afghanistan
and iraq during the iraq afghanistan
wars
we landed in we landed in afghanistan
and they told us if we tell you hit the
deck
hit the deck and we're like all right
we're just listening 30
30 minutes like hit the deck
oh my gosh [ __ ] yeah so we didn't even
spend the night there we only stayed for
like two hours and when we took off back
off we had two
f-18s flying with us ready to shoot
anybody down like if stuff happened holy
[ __ ] so crazy
we would go with a four-star general who
was
who would take us on these trips man
and then the scariest thing ever that
i've ever been in we were
in afghanistan and we're gonna fly to
cutter
and we we were in the rain it was
morning rain we were getting in the
helicopter in the rain
and we took off four military
helicopters take off
we're 10 minutes into the flight and we
look out the window and we see
shoe shoes and we're like
oh [ __ ] we just got shot at
and the pilot gets on uh yeah we're
gonna have to turn around
due to weather we're turning around
because we just got
shot at due to weather yeah it's raining
missiles
holy [ __ ] that's gnarly dude
yeah no it was one of the scariest
things i've been like
to be actually shot at you're like okay
this is gnarly
get ready this is going to be gnarly
pretty gnarly
kind of normal are we ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
[Music]
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
[Music]
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
[Music]
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off